next to where you have you're working
for your tier is also their company once
you get a nice clean sheet of paper or
still or friend or something like that
that and we're going to solve this
without tears alts we're going to solve
with auxilary angle okay
don't be saying I've seen a few times
auxilary angle and T results they're
both ways of rephrasing an awkward
question into a way that's better for us
to solve okay so sometimes you use to
you results because welcome you
sometimes used auxilary angle after we
go through this with you again go I'm
gonna let you decide which you prefer
some people will always lean what some
people like I just hate T results
whatever it is right doesn't matter if
it's good for T result I don't like it
so you always go from using angle some
people the reverse I'll let you make the
judgment okay
now let's have a look at it let's think
back to what we looked at with natural
forms half an hour ago okay what natural
form fits this best signs out the front
so it's going to be a sign 1 and as a
plus so it should be X plus alpha okay
so you start off by saying you know
remember but because both of these are
you know auxiliary I'm going to years
onto their book that rephrasing that's
why they both start off with let okay so
this time we're going to say let this be
equivalent to the natural form you just
told me sign X okay right now given that
I can say R I can go straight to this
line by the way if you ask me before
once you've established that this is
talking about what is a variable okay
you don't actually need to introduce the
park the garden and really you can just
say that's five squared plus 12 squared
and the reason why I'm going straight to
the positive values because ours at
airports you right so don't forget to
write that down so that's a perfect
square which is kind of handy place and
13
so now when I take my values for cos
alpha and sine alpha right I can see the
COS alpha is equal to now let's see here
when you do your expansion which one's
closed up we're going to go with because
it's signed that they're flipped around
so this cos alpha should go with this
side out
okay so this is five on thirteen if
you're ever unsure about that right
which on which just write out the full
expansion I'll try to show you that you
don't have to write out the full
expansion if you couldn't remember you
but if you do a few questions you're
like man I'm consistently getting things
wrong because I mix them up that's a
sign for you to write up the full thing
question you will not lose marks if you
get the question right if you get the
question wrong you will lose marks and
so you know often especially with like
this one because it's so common right
sorry Captain Obvious stays the day
right because so common right that's why
I haven't bothered to an expansion but
the other ones they don't come up nearly
as frequently so I'll write out these
fans just so I make sure I get the
coefficients right there's cos alpha
there's sine alpha they're both positive
we chose it so that they would both be
positive and I'll get an acute angle now
even though they're nice like numbers
okay be the number you're going to get
out is not exactly so what do you get
from alpha let's just go three decimal
places in radians hey what I've got is
one point one seven six
approximately okay can somebody stubble
check that I can better make sure yeah
okay great all right now I've got uh
I've got our fast so I can stay this
question up here when you guys are ready
thank you is equal to 13 sine x plus
this reader number here okay which is
equal to two right now that I've done
this now that I've actually changed my
equation here this has a different
domain to this right so impatient to
remember that this is actually six point
two eight okay just file that number for
wearing your head you knew it already
okay but just remember as we keep on
going through work
becomes very important all right let's
move that 13 over just so we can get
this in the right shape to pop into the
calculator so that's 2 over 13 you take
your sine inverse now when you take sine
inverse right
it will only tell you the first answer
right but obviously we're looking for
many many answers okay so when you write
down this first answer I think I've got
a 0.15 for you must remember there are
other ones here okay
now you might expect to dancers in fact
if you remember this question there are
two answers but I'm actually going to
write down a few more in this case I'm
going to write down three fours kind of
safe but it's sometimes excessive I'm
going to keep going right now sine is
positive sine is positive okay so in my
quadrants here I'm looking at this
quadrant here okay so the answer will
just be whatever I get for Thea in this
quadrant it's also positive right so
this would be 180 minus theta okay in
the second quadrant that's all white
answers we play this is 180 plus theta
and this is 360 so I should dump eyes
that's what you get for these two
quadrants but I'm not interested them in
them in this question because sine is
positive right so I'm just going to
ditch these two okay so here's answer
one here right my next one will be pi
minus that by minus point one five four
okay
ordinarily we'd stop but and I wonder if
you can see why I'm going to keep going
I'm going to do the next solution now
there's a solution in quadrant one
solution in Quadrant two can't do this
one can't do this when you come round
again what's the next solution it's this
plus two point because that's the period
of cycling so I'm going to go to PI plus
point one five four okay now maybe you
want to do a fourth one just to be safe
but it turns out to actually be okay in
this case this C solutions why don't
know two three
let's actually just get their arm let's
get their decimal values for all of them
when I'm working out 1 540 are two point
nine eight seven six three eight okay
where do we go from here
well on the left hand side I don't have
X on its own so just like with you know
T results often you know x over two over
here so you multiply through by 2 well
here I have to add by my alpha sorry
subtract so when you subtract one point
one six seven six off everything okay
here's what we're going to get okay so
can you see why I pulled out a third
solution okay because this first
solution do you talk the sort of
divergent written rhythms every angle is
no longer a valid solution okay it falls
outside the domain once you've actually
subtracted everything okay and this one
over here
six point four three eight that's
outside the normal domain right but we
change the domain and we moved it over
so actually when I subtract it comes
back within the domain that I laughter
okay so down here just to finish I would
say I would quote the domain I would say
but I'm between 9 and 2 pi okay
that's my reason for excluding this
first answer here okay so X is equal to
and I hope those numbers are familiar
from when we solved it the other day
okay so this is what the auxilary angle
working looks like you compare that put
it next to your T results working kind
of unsure um maybe because it's
unfamiliar like yeah I think I'm stickin
to results well maybe you hate them the
quadratics you get with T results makes
the working a bit longer I think if you
compare but you need to be able to do
both and choose which one you think is
going to be the figures yeah
yes sir tea results I mentioned this I
think just to you actually tea result
about sorry I start again auxilary angle
only works in this specific case where
you've got one wave function plus
another okay so a sine and a cosine just
one combination of those okay if you had
like a third wave function I'd say close
to X okay you don't get a big sign or a
big cos curve okay instead you get
something with extra Wiggles in it you
don't weird things like that so I can't
approximate that with just a sine curve
and change the amplitude and change what
about in the same way if you haven't an
in there Tan's not a wave function it's
got breaks it in that kind of thing so T
results so T onsen is a little more
versatile it can tackle a broader range
of problems but you get the x equals Pi
problem and people get more confused
with that domain then with okay